(claps)
- This ring is hurting.
I got to bring it up or something.
(swoosh)
(bang)
Hello Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about seven ways to build
huge followings on social media quickly.
(hip hop music)
So I've been getting a lot
of questions from you guys
about how to build an
audience on social media.
How do you get people to
care about your content?
How do you get people
to engage with the stuff
that you're making?
And so today I'm going
to share with you my
seven ways
to be able to build
huge audiences quickly.
Way number one is form alliances
and I like this strategy
not just for social media
but in business as well.
The fastest way to bring on an audience
to build a base is not to go
after people one at a time,
one at a time, one at a time.
It's to find somebody who
already has your target market
and find some way to
collaborate with them.
Find a way that you can offer value,
that you can help them out,
build some kind of connections
so that they will help
promote you to their base.
There's a couple ways that I did it
in the early days of my channel.
One, as an example, I
made thank you videos.
And so I looked at some
YouTubers that I looked up to.
I looked at Darrell Hughes,
and I looked at Tim Schmoyer,
and I looked at Gary Vaynerchuk
and then I though I like these guys,
I'm consuming their content,
I'm enjoying their stuff
and I'm being engaged on their videos.
And I thought, I want to thank them.
I'm going to make a
thank you video for them
but not just me thanking them,
I reached out to all of
their most active subscribers
and said hey I want to
make a thank you video
for Tim Schmoyer,
can you put together a
30 second quick thank you
'cause you like him too and
I'm going to mash them up
and put them together.
- Thank you very much Tim.
- I just want to say thank you so much for
all the help you have given to me.
- You've certainly made
a huge impact on my life
and my channel and I'm incredibly grateful
for your guidance.
- Surprise!
Hey.
- It's a lot of work.
But you need to find a way to stand out.
You need to find a way
to offer a lot of value.
If you're just getting started,
an interview with you
isn't really going to bring
somebody big a lot of value.
But doing a lot of work to
make a thank you video will.
And so everybody recognized it.
Everybody that I've done
it for was so grateful,
so thankful and it created openings,
it created opportunities for me
to get a lot more exposure.
With Tim, I did three
different guest videos
on his channel back when his channel was
bigger than mine.
I did three opportunities on his channel.
He's been on my channel.
We've done mastermind groups
and other projects together
and opened up a lot of
opportunities for us.
So find people who already
have your target audience.
They could be huge,
they could also be smaller.
And find a way to help them.
Whatever it is that you are great at,
find some way to add
value to their channel.
Another quick example,
I like helping entrepreneurs.
I've connected with other channels
who are not in the entrepreneur space
but might need some entrepreneur help.
Right, if somebody has a
YouTube channel talking about
YouTubes like Sass, you
know a lot of their audience
is going to still be entrepreneurs
even though the topic of the channel
is not entrepreneurship.
So I can reach out and
say hey I'm an expert on
entrepreneurship, I'd love
to collaborate on some kind
of video together to bring
value to your audience.
Forming collaborations and
alliances is one of the
fastest ways to build your
own audience for yourself.
Number two is you need to be prolific.
You need to create a ton of content.
It does a couple things.
One, it helps you get better.
Right?
The more you practice,
the better you'll get.
The quantity leads to the quality.
You can't just put up one
YouTube video and expect to
be great.
Your first YouTube video is probably
going to be pretty bad
'cause you've never done a video before
and the lighting will suck,
and the audio will suck,
and the editing will suck,
and you, your message,
your message will suck.
You know, 'cause you never had practice.
Be prolific.
Get really, really, really good.
I got better at YouTube and I became
the best at the agency that I'm with
from being the worst
in a couple of months 'cause
I did videos every day.
'Cause I grinded it out.
Because I practiced and I improved.
And if you go back on my channel,
go back six years ago,
and you'll see how boring and stiff I was
compared to how I am today.
- Hi I'm Evan Carmichael,
welcome to another edition
of Ask Evan.
This is my first post of the
year for Telesox Business
and we're starting a new series,
it's called The Challenge Series.
We're going to be answering
the questions of entrepreneurs.
And how did it go from there to here?
Just practice.
A lot of the points, a lot of the messages
are the same.
But my delivery is
better because I've done
three and a half thousand
videos on my channel
and most of them are public.
So you need to be prolific to get better.
You need to be prolific to
start attracting attention
when you create a video or
a post on a certain topic.
People who like that will find you,
or when you do collaborations
with other people,
see point number one,
they're going to come to your
channel and give you a shot.
Right?
Oh he just did a collaboration
with that person,
okay let me go check out his channel.
You have to have content on there.
Why am I going to subscribe
to your channel or follow you
if you don't have great content?
Right?
The collaboration gives you the opening,
it gives you some awareness.
They're going to hit your page.
They're going to see
your Instagram messages,
or your Facebook posts,
or your Tweets or your videos,
there has to be something
there that is quality
that people are going
to want to consume it,
and they consume it again
and again and again.
You have to be prolific.
Create
constantly.
One video a week is not enough.
One post a week is not enough.
Be prolific.
Number three is have a message.
This ties into my book
Your One Word but I believe
everybody has a message
and that has to come out.
Because people buy why
you're doing something
much more than what you're doing.
My message is Believe, it's my one word,
it oozes out of everything that I do.
And as a result I'm
known as the believe guy,
especially for entrepreneurs.
And whenever people see the word believe,
they're thinking of me.
I want people to be
able to think about you
and your mission and not just the content
that you're creating.
Because you might put out one great post,
fine, great they consume it.
I want to know why you're doing it.
I want to know the mission that you're on
to make the world a better place
and if I'm on that same mission,
I'm going to consume
everything that you create.
I want to watch every
video that you put up.
I want to see every Tweet that you push.
I want to see every Instagram
or Facebook picture.
I want to see every
Snap that you're writing
'cause I need more of that.
If you want more believe in your life,
you're going to love my content,
you're going to want to
consume as much as possible.
'Cause you need to believe in yourself
and your mission more.
The same thing for you.
What is your message?
What are you trying to get out there?
And does that ooze out of
every post that you put?
Now if you hate believe,
that believe is stupid,
believe isn't for me,
you're going to hate my content too.
Right?
Like you're not going to
want to watch anything,
you're not watching anymore on this video
'cause you don't like the
message, and that's fine.
I want people to love your message or not.
I don't want you just
be another person doing
the same thing.
Right, and so understanding
what your one word is,
understanding what your message is,
and then having that ooze
through every piece of content
makes a huge, huge, huge,
huge, huge difference
in the people that you'll attract
and the shareability of all your content.
Number four is model success.
Whenever you don't know
how to do something,
this has been my default go-to.
If I don't know how to do something,
I try to model success.
I try to find somebody who's
done what I want to do,
or close to it,
and see what worked for them,
what are they doing that is really working
and how can I take
pieces of it to help me.
And it's not being the next Steve Jobs,
or being the next Evan Carmichael,
or being the next Gary Vaynerchuk
or whoever it is that you look up to.
It's taking pieces from
them to help you be the best
version of yourself.
And so every time I've modeled success,
I couldn't do exactly what
that other person was doing
because it didn't feel right to me.
Not because I'm stealing their ideas,
just because the way
that it worked for them
I needed to tweak.
I always needed to tweak it.
But I understood their
strategy and once I tweaked it,
I could make it my own
and that's when I started
having success.
Where I had a media coach
helping me at my agency
to be better, we'd review videos
and she would tell me every
week something to work on.
And I always try, like
if you give me a task,
I'll try, I'll work it, I'll try to do it,
but it never felt perfectly right
because that's her view.
That's what she would do.
That's what she's seen
work in her own stuff.
And I can't be her.
And I always needed to
tweak it to make it my own
but there was always a growth lesson.
Everything she told me,
I could always find a way
after some uncomfortableness of trying
to then say I like that,
I'm going to go here and do this.
And so whenever you don't know what to do,
model success.
Find the people who've done it,
bring it to work for your company.
Number five is get in the media.
More, more, more, more
traditional media are looking
to the people on social media
as experts.
So whatever it is that
you're an expert in,
and you should be an expert at something,
you have expert opinions on things.
And any time somebody's
writing a story on something,
they're always looking for an expert.
And so I'd be looking
at who the reporter is
in traditional media that
are covering your space.
And then any time they
write a story about it,
you're reaching out.
And you can give some commentary on it.
And the next time they write
a story they're going to
remember you and what you're all about,
and what you're doing.
Understand that reporters
have a hard time.
Reporters are not the
experts on a lot of things.
They always need these
guest people to come in
and give them more insight and context
to help their stories
because they need a source for
every story that they write.
If you are a credible source
that has great information,
you're making their life easier.
You're making the life
of that reporter easier.
And they're going to come
back to you again, and again
and again any time they have something
that covers your niche.
And so I'd be reaching out to reporters,
especially if you're using social,
most of them are on some
kind of social platform
whether it's Twitter,
whether it's Instagram,
whether it's LinkedIn,
you can find them on social,
it's way easier than ever before.
Comment on their stories,
show yourself to be
a successful expert,
to know what you're talking about,
to add value to their content,
and then the next time
they're doing an interview
they're going to be talking about you.
You sharing your amazing opinions.
Number six is get some help.
I'm not a big believer in spending money
until you're making money,
but if you found the
path to be able to make
some money from this,
whether you're doing social content
and that helps drive business for you
either selling product or services,
as soon as you start making some money
from your social path,
then bring on some help.
Bring on people to give you assistance.
For me, on YouTube, the
first person I hired
was an editor.
I was doing everything at the start.
And I had money.
I just don't like spending
money until I'm making it.
I could've taken money and started it all
and got the lights and gear and camera
and all that stuff.
But I didn't know if I was
going to stick with it.
And the worst that you can
do is spend a ton of money
on something, try it twice,
and then give up on it and you're sitting
with all this expensive
gear in your basement
that you can't get rid of.
And so I was the camera
man, I was the researcher,
I was in front and behind the camera,
I was editing, I was
doing all the analytics,
everything, I was everything
for my YouTube channel to start.
And as soon as I started
to get some traction,
and I was generating sales for me,
I hired an editor and
that allowed me to move
from a video a week to a video a day.
And now we're up to three
to five videos a day
depending on the day,
because I built up my team.
We've got more people working for me.
And so thinking about what
you're really great at.
Are you great at designing?
Are you great at writing?
Are you great at copy?
Are you great at being
in front of the camera?
Are you great at editing?
Are you great at strategizing?
What is your strengths?
And as soon as you can afford it,
bringing on people to
compliment your strengths
to take over your weaknesses so you can be
even more prolific with
higher quality stuff
that you can put out.
And number seven is you
have to be passionate.
Whenever you are
passionate about the things
that you are doing, you
will get better results.
If you are creating content
because somebody else
is creating content,
or you're posting something
up because you think
it's going to be a hot thing,
but you don't have any interest in it,
it's not going to work.
You're not going to get the right people.
You have to create the
things that make you excited.
That you would want to show
your kids and grandkids.
That should be the acid test.
If you're making a piece of content,
whether it's a video or
a picture or a blog post
or whatever it is,
you're making a piece of content,
make something that you
want to show your grandkids
and say look what I made.
And if that passion comes
through into every piece
of content that you're creating,
I promise you, you are going
to attract like-minded people
who also love the work that you're doing,
and will be your ambassadors for you.
Where if all you're trying to do is
chase click bait titles,
and you don't actually care
that much about those topics,
you'll get some people coming in,
but they're not going to stick.
They're not going to join your movement.
They're not going to
really want to follow you.
They're not going to really
share all of your future stuff
because you're not deeply
connected to the message.
And so it's super important
that when you're creating
this content you feel
connected to every single piece
and you want to show it to your grandkids.
So those are my seven tips
on how to build a massive
audience super quickly.
I'd love to know what do you guys think?
What was your favorite tip?
What is most relevant and
applicable to your business
that you're going to start
immediately working on?
Did I miss some?
Is there an eight, nine, ten that you guys
want to add to the list?
Leave it in the comments below,
super curious to figure out
what you guys are going to say.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Danijel.
Danijel, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word,
for posting an awesome review on Amazon,
along with the two pictures.
I really, really, really
appreciate the love and support
and hope you're enjoying the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.